in India digitalization is moving
aggressively forward with the launch of
5G Services across major cities it's
been an incredible decade that has seen
hundreds of millions of citizens get
online and everything from digital
payments to social media has been
booming under this government however
the growth has been commensurate with
more online censorship the latest
development will see the establishment
of a committee to make decisions about
disputed online posts DW's Adele bot
reports on the digital environment in
the country start
the things in Delhi are one of India's
most followed social media influencer
families
the new influencers who have become an
internet sensation overnight because of
India's digital Revolution
every week this family produces dozens
of videos on YouTube and Instagram
ranging from short films to dance videos
ramnik Singh the head of the family says
for them content is everything earlier
without internet without this reach
there were no opportunities for people
like us who are social media influencers
we are earning lot of money as well you
know it's a huge economic impact on our
lives and all this again is happening
why because of the internet India's
digital footprint has tripled in less
than a decade
sixty percent of Indians now have access
to the internet
this expansion has changed the lives of
millions of people across the country to
expand his digital Footprints the Indian
government launched the digital India
program in 2015. the main aim of this
ambitious program is to connect more
people online from the remote areas and
to transform the country into digitally
empowered Society
in the bustling markets of Delhi one of
the most Visible Changes is the
transition to digital payments
from t-stall owners to big businesses
digital payments have become their new
mode of transaction
R has been running this t-stall for
several years
in recent months he has noticed a clear
shift among customers who prefer digital
payments or cash
the majority of customers I get these
days want to pay online
no one carries cash digital payments
also make it quick and easy for us
but this massive expansion of India's
digital space comes with its own
setbacks the country has the highest
number of Internet shutdowns imposed by
state and Central governments last year
the internet service was cut in India
106 times
and so far this year 93 shutdowns have
taken place
there are also other impediments like
disinformation and growing censorship
which critics say are rampant since the
Hindu nationalist government came to
power in 2014.
for the internet
International an organization that
defends online freedom
the situation in India is a cause of
concern
I think India's Rising instances of
Internet shutdowns fits into a larger uh
Trend towards eroding democratic ideals
online censorship in particular in India
is a highly opaque process if your
speech or your website or your YouTube
video gets taken down by the government
you are never told why this happened as
a result you never have an opportunity
to contest this with a powerful blend of
government initiatives to improve and
expand connectivity
India's digital Revolution is gathering
peace however it comes with the fear of
increasing censorship and a slide
towards digital authoritarianism
is south Asia editor of rest of
world.com a newsroom that covers
technology in the global South I spoke
to her earlier she started by explaining
the Dynamics of how so many aspects of
Indian life are going online all while
the Indian government regularly censors
the internet
Well India right now is at a very
strange Crossroads where digitization
and internet adoption is at its peak
compared to ever any time in the past uh
there are like you know it is the
largest market for Facebook for WhatsApp
it is one of the largest markets for
Instagram for instance but at the same
time uh there is little to no regulation
in certain spaces and uh there are like
you know the the policy making in that
sense is still catching up which leaves
a lot of room for things to uh go in
wrong directions there are risks for
instance uh to give you an example data
protection is a big question in India
because we do not have very clear
guidelines on it and the government has
been working for some time to come up
with clear data protection regulations
but in the absence of that the millions
of Indians who use the internet who use
social media on a daily basis are left
vulnerable to some extent uh to your
question about censoring again you know
that stems from the policies because a
lot of policies are still being made as
we go there's no Clarity so there is
room for people to manipulate or to um
like you know to use them to their
advantage do you think at some point
that this is going to impact the
trajectory of the Indian tech boom if
the government oversteps uh in terms of
its censorship or control that you see
that Tech boom slowing down
uh this is a question it's a very
interesting question I have been
discussing it with experts a lot lately
uh uh the question I suppose is that uh
there will there might be a difference
in way Indian youth interacts with the
internet but the growth of an internet
in India or growth of Technology the
startup boom may not really slow down
simply because India is has one of the
youngest populations in the world a
large chunk of our citizens are under
the age of 30 which means uh they want
to be on the internet they want to use
internet in different ways uh so the the
penetration in that sense will continue
to grow people will keep aspiring to be
entrepreneurs but yes the way in which
they use it the way they they interact
with technology the startups the kind of
startups that come out there might be
some impact of policies or the way the
governments and states and Center have
been behaving they might they might
impact that
and this is a challenge for governments
around the world I mean the European
Union the United States are grappling
with the same challenges in terms of
regulating tech companies and also how
they manage that online content what's
your biggest criticism of India's
approach here so far
I feel that you know one thing that we
have really lagged is we have not been a
proactive in policy making so you know
any of the issues to do with whether it
is Data privacy or to do with free
speech on the internet that you see in
recent years coming out of India I
believe those would be solved is if the
government of the policy makers had been
proactive in framing policies that keep
Pace with the technological development
and Innovation that's been having a lot
of the laws in India are still archaic
they are like uh 100 100 years old and
the world has changed since then and if
we keep fighting battles about internet
privacy and about free speech on the web
with those same archaic laws we will
never have Clarity on what's right
what's wrong what I see in EU for
instance is that there are policies that
many countries have been making which
keep Pace with the reality of today and
I feel that is one thing that India will
really benefit from if we took Stern
quick decisions about policies which
will save that the citizens also not
just like you know not just the
community that is Raising concerns
against say a government or a political
party but having clear policies will
also Safeguard citizens in India from uh
like you know from from the in the
technology world that person
thank you so much for joining us
thank you